[Musique]
ok
qu'est ce qu'on a
un homme 40 ans sa triple d'une heure qu
il est là il menace de sauter puis il
veut pas qu'on la proche
sale journée on est tous passés par là
on va discuter d'accord non j'ai pas
envie de discuter j'ai plus envie de
rien foutez moi la paix ok ok ca attendu
ici je m'allume une clope non plus mais
j'ai arrêté
bravo
moi je m'appelle john curtis enchanté et
curtis en dix mois c'est quoi le
problème
problème c'est que la vie c'est de la
merde voilà j'ai plus de boulot j'ai
plus de fric plus d'amis six tours ou
bien un truc qui vaut le coup sur cette
terre et marié non ouais j'ai une femme
et deux gosses et bah ça ça ça vaut le
coup qu'on s'accroche qu'on wiimote
toujours soutenu même dans les pires
moments des enfants ça change la vie
ouais c'est vrai vous en avez vous êtes
mariés vous avez une fiancée une copine
alors peut-être une coloc avec keith un
peu ambigu parce que parfois ce moment
je vis seule je laime ma famille vous
savez c'est pour ça je peux pas leur
imposer un looser comme à ce maire
d'anefis est depuis toujours
vous savez c'est si c'est mon pouce
jusqu'à 8 ans mais c'est rien ça c'est
du passé
moi j'ai pissé au lit jusqu'à 16h donc
quoi non rien rien il a dit qu'il
pissait olive unsa c'est bon c'est celui
qu'un de mes gars phone qui parle
d'accord jusqu'à 16 ans 16 ans je suis
père tard non c'est carrément bizarre il
faut que c'est fou trouvé personne non
mais l'important c'est d'avoir été
exactement curtis arrêter tu sais ton
pouce était devenu un homme
un mari et un père de famille et ça
c'est pas rien ah bah alors ça c'est pas
rien et c'est même beaucoup
on n'est rien sur l'amour d'une famille
désolé n'en sais rien
tout va bien à curtis aux conques là
n'ont rien vous fumez beaucoup quoi vous
avez essayé de vapoter parce que j'ai un
pote qui a fait ça et non mais j'ai tout
essayé je n'arrive pas façon j'arrive à
rien vous avez réussi à être policier
quand même c'est pas tout le monde qui
peut y arriver quand même vous protéger
la société vous vous occupez des gens
c'est super je m'occupe des gens puis
quand je rentre chez moi qui s'occupent
de moi personne
vous avez bien des amis n'ont pas sûr
qu'il faut faire sauter les pv j'en ai
plein d amis il ya forcément des gens
qui tiennent à vous votre collègue là
elle a l'air bien vous aimez jusqu'à 16
ans mais le point positif c'est que j'ai
ça comme ça si j'ai envie d'en finir ben
je peux faire ça tranquillement à la
maison mais dit pas des trucs pareils
tiens je vais peut-être faire s'asseoir
pourquoi pas toi façon jumeaux kaki ah
non mais tu connais pas en rester là
ça va oui ça fait 16 ans jusqu'à 16 ans
d'accord faire en tenant la corde
série beaucoup d'amour toi tu as encore
fait le coup du célibataire
mon héros
par contre encore passé au lit
[Musique]